they say Capella's or penance or parents
or parents or parents and planners are
sober my uncle woody recipe call it my
blessings I feel like I'm pulling the
birdie is back tell me I'm Bobby's I'm
footman deciding that's why calling me
this is not birthday present from look
at the rats
[Music]
you've got surprisingly good tolerance
for whiskey I'm not friendly did 26
Roman coats thank you key thing about
this event and it's annoying it was it
was a mate I've got pizza the number
goes up everything to me so it's 42
there's a black shirt with the cups but
if you kept the cups Rodney or
someone shot it is the world
[Music]
you don't plug a fine whiskey tell you
what I really enjoyed vlog wise and
everyone's gonna sit there second off
Morgan's last video was flow very nice I
feel as well since Logan after the fire
has been heavily inspired by David Ober
and Mike being a 35 year old dude is
like forcing the maturity to be put into
the vlogs last time I watched him he
just had like five [__] of the top
porn stars in the world in in one room
Bryan doesn't send me many videos he's
sent me that video and he went we should
do more like this Ilana roads I watched
a video of her she took about 11 inches
of our [__] it was nothing I was like
[__] me well no wonder Mike's [__]
can't leave her alone how do you think a
parent of hers feels when they see those
they see the money coming in and they go
[__] it do what you want do you think
yeah definitely this is the future
because the amount of girls now who are
having only funds account who've just
like normal random girls Nate and
they're just like [__] paying the bills
like just [__] I'm just gonna get me
tips out on Orly fun y'all that keep
seeing every now and then on these love
Bible pages and things like that should
keep seeing I made 90 grand a month or
two months on all the funds was like
really exactly it's becoming more normal
but I think ten years ago people would
say oh you're a slag you can meet and
only friends in life what are you
showing off your body and stuff but now
it's becoming more normal
I think you'll in the future you be
there is a record on line four of your
to your family to see and your children
to see way of you owning a penis and so
these girls aren't doing that imagine a
girl find out her dad part of the only
funds are coming like that would be my
let's be quite a self-esteem boost as
well if you get in people that watching
yeah but that's not but it's a false
boost why how's that fault be because
it's your self-esteem if you oppose it
was the only new swimming shorts and you
were getting hundreds of girls around
the world paying 1000 choice of me in my
spare your speedo
your Rican girls are pay 10 Panama yes I
mean first of all that's just rude I
don't know you've credit the laws
alright well we're on it
the man's in batter [__] they're not in
a long time
[Music]
why is your lip quivering you're nervous
you're nervous
well there's a little bit the ocean what
getting in that is the wierdest bit yeah
he drops water everywhere doesn't let me
look at him admits he's nervous and
Jason laughing he's out of fire yeah cuz
get Mo's definitely not compensating you
see that they're the kind of friends
from believe in rooster biology doesn't
lie he literally rubbed his hands there
I think the pressure is gonna play a
massive part of Jake in this fight there
is for you being convinced that Jake's
gonna we'll fight it from day one
hundred-percent If Jake loses against a
Nissan get a fifa youtuber that is a
huge blow to his image a man with more
to lose is far more dangerous than a man
with nothing like you know what I'm
saying like I think there's no quitting
Gabe don't get us wrong but I think Jake
is gonna like he would hang on for dear
life here the biggest mistake people are
making is they're looking at the JJ law
of infighting thinking yep it's gonna be
the same as that Jake Paul is not the
same as Logan he's like sounds nothing
like Logan one is their mother and one
is their father even like said it not
completely agree Logan there's like a
really warm caring guy I'm not saying
like Jake is a complete [__] like a
lot of people think he is he is more
like ruthless in the indium in the mall
one of the main problems that we all
that you said especially Jill his Logan
wouldn't pull the trigger
he's gonna [__] pull the trigger I'm
not my words there's gonna be no [__]
or is this the right moment I'm not
gonna hit the right he's gonna be buggin
the right hand from the get-go I
remember back in the day we met Dan
Hardy and he started banging on about
something called the reptilian brain and
how you have to switch emotions off when
you get in a cage or a ring and do what
you're like you're needing to do to win
not not what not where your emotions are
telling you to do and I know for a fact
Jake stop give-give fights emotionally
in my opinion I've watched him fight
before the way he fights he fights like
an absolute lion but in but in a
potentially detrimental way so if Jason
lucky and have you seen stars and Jake
Paul's been training a lot since that
last fight and with quality I just worry
like because I don't think Jake is
emotional in the ring no way and as a
brawl when you meet him I've interviewed
a lot
people he was the hundred I've never met
anyone like him who is like reptilian
like there's a it's hard to get
something anything else exactly and that
is why I think he's gonna win this fight
because everyone's like the pressures
gonna get to him the moments gonna get
you're in my opinion against edgy that
was the best boxing performance of any
youtube ofc everyone said that Jay Paul
didn't have the balls to take on a
Nissan Cube because he was the best
YouTube boxer but because he had nothing
to give Jay Palmer's alright is that the
case is that I'll [__] do him then so
no one's given Jay credit for taking
this fight you should be because he's
got everything to lose
everyone said he wouldn't have the balls
to do it and he's still getting in there
and fight them so if he then goes in and
then chased them out we've all got us a
fair fight
you know what I mean I also think that
shows Jake's you could spin that and say
that shows Dex Jake's desperation to get
JJ I'm sure okay when you know I don't
go through Gibb to get to I wrote that
like you want to fight this guy so bad
you're willing to go against a little
tornado and gibble whom I [__] you up
and that's how bad you want so that is
the story though that is the story
Jake beats Gibb chaos RJ thanks a lot
and my imagine you know they're gonna
get Jay Jay's storm in the ring
celebrating with gibble which would be
amazing okay all we're going to get jig
ballpoint Lynn ginge ago yeah you're
next either way it's bottom
[Music]
[__] right now
Monica says we're not predictions boys
productions I'm saying that jake has got
this
I bet on rounds one two three watch a
Pathan give wings to be honest yeah for
me I think he's shown the most
improvement are the two of them and I
think to even get into this position
shows the kind of guy that is I'm the
same seven figure giver all to a winner
givers gonna go out he's gonna add too
much presence Jay Paul Jay Paul's not
gonna be able to deal with the pressure
he's gonna get knocked out round 4 so
we'll see ya you're saying not bro yeah
I've seen a TKO and I say a complete
knockout nothing clear now he's gonna
finish room to be completely honest I
see Sugar Shane Mosley throwing in the
towel in the fourth round going you know
what I will Sugar Shane Mosley is about
noise display the clay everyone's gonna
be coming in he's gonna be applying a
lots of pressure
he's gonna overextend he's gonna find
his chin wide open and Gabe is going to
get pork with the right hand that's
gonna be the beginning at the end he's
gonna be checked really hard in the jaw
he's gonna stagger and at that point
we're gonna see the rest stop it over
Venice a jig hit him again
drop them get back nod and then stop the
fight it's going to be stopped gibble
with all that pressure is gonna be wide
open and he's going to be hurt badly
okay that's my bet it's gonna be a right
hand full if kibble proves me wrong here
I think they'll be like one of the most
amazing moments in internet history
badal Riley is in the [__] ring I love
this guy here we go you ain't ready for
me kibbles soon you were ready for me
this is my time
famously I put 260 pound on Logan to
bring the last five and where did it go
yeah I guess what
this time I've done a Nissan Cube how
much 10 pound it is a math it is about I
musta made credit a JJ right he's on to
her sob sister in Dublin he goes jump on
a plane Miami back onto our
this means a lot to him yeah he's
supporting his boy like seven-figure
Gaber
let's go come on Gabe the remaining calm
is the most important thing for both
guys right now he's ducking down
avoiding those hooks it but it just
depends on whether or not you can handle
two shots when they come in because as
you're charging ahead you're gonna get
clipped and it's can he handle up see
we're witnessing a little bit early on
of him give him in caught a little bit
by Jake yeah yeah I've seen two shots
around already if Jay moves forward
they'll be interest to say of gibble
handles that we're seeing we're seeing
Antigone Gibble's being dropped in the
first two minutes of the fight
James Jake's gonna smell come on yeah
Jake's gonna smell Jake's catching him
repeatedly already on its a left hook by
Jay Paul and the procedures are looking
good for being a standing come already
since Russ isn't looking good for I'm
telling you no Lutz he's gonna need to
be more strategic he's getting jabbed
repeatedly by Jake Paul right now job
left straight yellowness straight left
this is gonna blend this nipple isn't
like it's a body shot and it's a left -
this is lasting long Jake Paul is having
the halitosis in this first round and
you can see another job what you can see
what's get boards because he's so
excited he's described as a pole and
he's got it shameful I'm telling you
lads this is what I predicted
dude dude that was one with traffic I
love giveaways a great life why this
needed to be stopped because kibble
would have been badly knocked over Todd
that have carried on it wouldn't have
been a big coyote yeah Benkei I want to
say that we don't want to see keyboard
cat K on the guy went in against a much
bigger lot quite at a table like he's
got balls if they should need me in the
same week like I'm not saying
disappointed by that he's gonna bring
more than that and I think he'll be
disappointed when looks back and looks a
strategy in matter but I think the thing
that gave wanted it was just land up
punished if carries respect and he never
got his respect and in a fight like this
with a bigger man you have to give them
something to worry about no Jake was
Jake was fighting on the back
you know it's hard to do that you know
you're still touching them but you get
landed a couple of punches and eat the
problem is if you lands and you don't
get that respect then you got a real
problem
it wasn't like give all bottle this you
give everything business get ma quit
constantly people aren't gonna give Jake
the credit he deserves here no matter
what
despite the fact that everyone said he
would bottle it and not fake it
he's winning in for cube I don't care if
you like it or not give him the [__]
respect they deserve I questioned you
beforehand on your you know assumption
of JP and they're the best of the UT
boxes after his fight against their G
you can't cover Joe well if I this is a
real example of his class with Sugar
Shane Mosley pot pot training them we've
got a different beast here or there with
this face and let me go they're facing
off now oh one thing that none of us
know in the room right now is how does
ksi do against cable only care side
knows that won't even our laws I don't
know I've never had the conversation but
ksi will know just by looking at how
Gibble's justice being dismantled by Jay
how he is in comparison to Jake on a
level and it's going to give them a lot
of thing about this let you say it
Mayweather McGregor of YouTube this is
it all right that's enough [__] talking
from the slot hope you enjoyed the fight
we know if they welded the ball if the
lads oh you mean a thought on our money
I hope you had a good time I hope you
both get back in there do it again we'll
love you hit the like button subscribe
thanks for watching